if you're afraid of your own body that  your own body is going to cause you pain  suffering and maybe even death  then you are living in this schism like  you and your body are somehow at war  which is literally what we've been  conditioned around  think about even the semantics of our  medications  antibiotics which literally  etymologically means against  life antibiotics antihypertensives  antidepressants  we are enculturated around warfare with  the  self because if we fight ourselves of  course it's a  losing battle an endless battle then we  will never recognize  who the true enemy of illusion is it  fits very seamlessly  into a model that would keep us enslaved  and so the shift has to come from  understanding  that symptoms are you telling you  about you they are informational  translation  from the soul to the mind to the  awareness